[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANISH DALWADI: Hi, folks.
Thanks for coming.
My name's Manish.
I'm a product manager on
Google Compute Engine.
Today, we're going to be
talking about saving money
on Compute Engine.
Before we dive into
the topic, there
is a Dory for this session.
My amazing colleague
Scott's going
to be moderating it, so
if any questions pop up
while we're going
through the talk,
feel free to post
those questions there.
And we'll answer some
of those questions,
as well as take some live
questions at these remotes
at the end of the session.
So wasting money on cloud
is a very real problem.
Our friends at Rightscale
do an annual survey.
Basically every
year, they do this.
And just like last year,
they found that 35% of cloud
spend is being lost.
That's a very large number.
And what's causing it is a host
of different things, right?
It may be that you're running
instances or resources that you
no longer need anymore.
Or you've over
provisioned resources,
or you just haven't bought the
right discounts for the things
that you are running today.
But regardless, 35%
over the past two years
straight is a pretty big number.
And it's not because
customers don't care.
The majority of
respondents in the survey
cite cloud optimization
cloud cost as a top concern.
Yet the number is still so big.
And the reason for that
is it's not easy, right?
Cloud is a really dynamic place.
Things are constantly changing.
There's new features coming
to Compute Engine every week
or every month.
And then your
actual environment,
you have resources coming and
going at whatever churn rate.
You have no idea
[INAUDIBLE] times.
So it can be really
hard to keep up.
So in today's talk, what
we're going to focus on
are what are some of
the common patterns
for waste in terms
of cloud spend
and what you can do about it.
We'll tackle that
in four section.
The first, we'll
talk about how Google
thinks about pricing products.
The second is we'll
talk about understanding
what are the resources that
you're actually paying for.
If you don't understand what
the resources you're paying for
are, it's really hard
to optimize those costs.
And then we'll talk
about those common areas
where waste happens and
what are tactical things you
can do to remove that waste.
And then finally, we'll
close on optimizing
the types of
discounts you can make
or purchase to help optimize
the actual resources that you're
running.
So let's get started.
We'll talk about pricing
principles first.
So when we at Google Cloud
think about pricing products,
we try to keep three
principles in mind--
simple, flexible, and fair.
Now, these principles can
mean a lot of different things
to different people.
So let me talk through
each one of these
and describe what
it means to us.
Simple means powerful enough to
meet your needs without being
unnecessarily complex.
And so that doesn't mean
that a five-year-old should
be able to understand
your cloud bill,
but it also doesn't
mean that you
should be required to have a
PhD in finance to figure out
your cloud bill.
And so one of the
features that we
have that we launched last year
is something called resource
based pricing.
Resource based pricing basically
charges or meters usage
against each resource
as an independent SKU.
So it's super easy
to figure out where
you're spending your money.
So you could look at
it and say, oh, I'm
spending x dollars on
cores, y dollars on RAM,
and some money on some
premium OS licenses.
So there's no weird bundles
to sort of reverse engineer.
There's no hidden costs.
It makes things super simple,
and easy, and transparent
to figure out what's
going on your bill.
Flexible.
So we get it.
Things change over time.
And you shouldn't be scared to
make a decision today and be
punished if things
change in the future.
So this is something that
we spend a lot of time
on with our pricing models.
We think really hard about
how do we make things flexible
enough so that our pricing
models can evolve and adapt
to your evolving workloads
and your changing workloads.
One example of this is something
that we call committed use
discounts.
And the idea with
committed use discounts
is you purchase an
aggregate commitment
for x amount of
resources, say, 1,000
cores in a specific region.
And in exchange,
you say I'm going
to pay for that for
one or three years.
And you can get some fairly
deep discounts this way.
But what makes committed
use discounts flexible
is that we're not asking
you for a specific machine
shape, or a specific zone,
or a specific operating
system, or network type,
or anything like that.
You're just telling us what
region and the amount of cores.
And now you can run
whatever VMs you want.
So VMs can come and go.
You can change shapes.
You can change zones
within the region.
You can change
operating systems.
Those commitments that
you made on day one
will continue to apply.
So the whole goal here
is that you shouldn't
have to feel afraid to make
some of these commitments
on our platform.
And then finally, fair.
Fair first and foremost means
a low competitive price always.
What it also means, though,
is that if we see that you're
wasting money in some way--
for example, if you're running
an over provisioned instance
and we notice it--
we're going to get in your face.
And we're going to
tell you about it
so that you can take action.
We call that instance
right sizing.
Another thing that
we do or what's
sort of driven from
our fairness ideal
is if you happen to do
something with your workload
and it saves Google
money, it's only fair
that we pass those
savings on to you.
So for example, if you run a
resource for an entire month,
that gives efficiency to Google.
And so Google should pass some
of those savings on to you.
And so we do exactly that with
something called sustained use
discounts.
You don't need to
tell us anything.
You just run your
workload, and if you
happen to run it for some
steady state within the month,
you'll automatically
get discounts.
And this commitment to
simplicity, flexibility,
and fairness is not something
that you find with all cloud
providers and
definitely not something
that you've seen from all
cloud providers from day one.
So let's move on to
the second section.
We're going to start talking
about understanding what
are you actually getting charged
for in terms of the resources
that you run within
Compute Engine.
So at a high level,
you can group
the resources into
two buckets, the base
VM, which is the cores and RAM,
and the attachable resources.
So these are things like GPUs,
persistent disk, licensing,
and there's a whole
bunch of other
little-- not little-- but
other resources like local SSD.
So one of the things
here is one of the core
things around Compute Engine
is providing visibility
into the resources
that you're running.
And so when you're trying
to optimize your cost,
you want to understand where
you're spending your money.
So a lot of Compute
Engine customers spend--
most of their spend ends up
on their base VM, the cores
and RAM.
But there are
attachable resources
that can be quite expensive,
like a V100 GPU, for example.
And so optimizing your GPU
spend can also have a material
impact on your overall bill.
And so with resource based
pricing, which is something
that we talked about
a little bit earlier,
it's really easy to get a
picture of what you're actually
spending your money on.
And so you can kind of
stack rank and focus,
where do I need to spend the
most attention initially, which
could be your cores and RAM.
Or if you're a
heavy GPU user, you
may be wanting to
optimize your GPUs.
So how do you figure out what's
actually running right now?
So if you want to
understand what's
happening at a point
in time right now,
you can take advantage
of our instance list
and describe APIs.
So with the List API, you get
a list of all of the instances
that are currently
running on your project.
And then you can
use the instance
Describe API to see what
exactly that instance is.
And so the cost
driving fields here
are things like
machine type, right?
So this is the base
VM, the core and RAM.
There's also accelerator type
and accelerator accounts.
So these are the GPUs
that are running,
and the number of GPUs,
and the type of GPU.
There's your disk.
And so there could be
multiple disk objects
within that resource in the API.
So you could have persistent
disk, multiple persistent disks
attached to your VM, or you
could have a local SSD disk
as well.
And local SSD can also be a
fairly expensive resource.
And then you can
also take a look
at what's running in terms of
the licensing or the premium
OS's attached to the
VMs that you're running.
So, seeing what's running at
sort of that moment in time
is useful, but a lot of
cloud environments, what's
running right now is
not indicative of what
ran four months ago or
over that period of time
between four months
ago and today.
And so for that type
of historical analysis,
we have a really,
really awesome tool.
It's called BigQuery
Billing export.
Once you enable this export,
what basically happens
is all the usage that is
charge against your project
and all the different SKUs
will get logged and put
into a BigQuery data set.
And then you can do analysis on
that data set for whatever time
frame you want.
The main thing that
I would point out
is that it's not
sort of retroactive.
So once you enable it,
that is when the data
will start getting stored.
So you're not going to
get historical data if you
haven't activated it yet.
And so the idea here
is really simple.
It's a really simple
example that's up here.
You can ask the
data set to give you
all of the SKUs
associated with Compute
Engine for a specific project,
or for a billing account,
or multiple projects
if you want.
And then you group
by the SKU name.
And then sum up
the cost, and then
sort in descending
order by the cost.
And what that will give
you in terms of an export
is exactly all of the specific
resources that you're paying,
from the most expensive on your
bill all the way to your least
expensive.
So in this example, it's a
bunch of N1 standard cores,
some N1 standard RAM, and then
there's some V100 GPUs running.
So this is a really,
really powerful tool,
so something I really encourage
you folks to turn on when you
start creating your products.
Or if you already have
a project, turn it on.
It's a great way to sort
of analyze what's happening
and assess what you
should do in terms
of optimizing your cloud costs.
So now I want to introduce
a fictional company.
I took some of the usage
patterns from a real company
and applied it here.
But this is not a real company.
It's Example Inc. They just
ramped up on Compute Engine.
They're spending about
$1.4 million a year now.
They've done no work to
optimize their bills.
So nothing.
They just started
creating instances.
So there's probably a lot
of low hanging fruit here.
And the purpose of
this example company
is to help illustrate
some of what
an optimization can
do on the overall bill
for a semi-real example.
And just to make sure that
we're all kind of aligned,
so they're spending 1.4 million.
They've got a whole
bunch of cores.
So they have 230 VMs running
across different VM shapes.
They've got some GPUs,
just eight V100s.
They've got about 120
terabytes of PD SSD.
And they're also running
some Windows workloads.
So let's take Example Inc on
the journey of doing some cost
optimization.
So the first thing we
would say to Example Inc
is pick the right size for
your workload, instance size
for your workload.
And Compute Engine offers
a great deal of flexibility
here with something that we
call custom machine shapes.
And a lot of other
cloud providers,
what they require you to do
is choose between a fixed list
of predefined machine shapes.
And sometimes what
that means is that you
have to pick a
machine that is bigger
than what you need in terms
of cores, RAM, or local SSD.
That's basically waste.
With custom machine
types, what you can do
is pick the right
amount of cores,
the right amount
of memory, and not
have to overpay for
the cores and RAM
that you would have to do with
the predefined machine type.
So a couple of caveats
with custom machine types.
There are some restrictions.
So if you want a
custom machine type,
you have to do it in
increments of two vCPUs--
so two, four, six, eight--
and then 0.25
gigabytes of memory.
Even with those sort of
caveats or restrictions,
custom machine types
are significantly more
flexible than most
predefined machine types
that you see out there.
So there's real
cost savings here
if you leverage
custom machine types.
So if you have VMs
running right now
or you're going to be launching
instances in the future,
think about right sizing them.
You may be over
provisioning these VMs,
and there's significant savings
here for you potentially.
So generally, most
predefined machine types
are in shapes of what
we call powers of 2.
And so that's 2,
4, 8, 16, 32, 64.
And the reason
that is, is that it
makes bin packing on the
cloud provider side really,
really easy.
So it's great for the provider,
but it's not great for you
because you're forced to
pay for resources that you
don't actually need.
So let's take an example.
Let's say you want to run--
you need 20 cores.
In the old powers of 2 world,
what you'd be stuck with
is a 32 core VM.
And that means you're
paying for 12 extra cores
that you don't need.
So that doesn't seem really
fair from our pricing principle
perspective, right?
So take advantage of
custom machine types.
Take a look at what you
can do to shrink down
your VMs to the right size.
So in order to do
that actual step,
there's a little
code snippet here.
The idea here is you
stop the instance.
So there's an outage.
You would change
the shape of the VM,
and then you would start
the instance backup.
And it would reconnect all
your PDs and all of that.
So there is an outage.
So you want to be-- do it
during your maintenance windows,
or if it's not
critical as a dev test,
you can just do it
whenever it makes sense.
So figuring out if you
are over provisioning
an instance is not necessarily
a simple task, right?
Workloads can change over time.
So you'd have to have
a lot of telemetry.
You'd be trying to see
what's happening to the VM
and trying to figure out, oh,
should I right size it or not?
So following our
principles around fairness,
we watch instances.
We see the utilization rates.
And so if we notice
a VM that's being
underutilized or
even over utilized,
we're going to tell you.
We're going to get in
your face, and we're
going to tell you about it.
And so we call this
rightsizing recommendations.
This is available in GA today.
You can just log into
the cloud console.
Go to the instance, the
Compute Engine instance page.
And you'll see a list of
recommendations there.
And with a push of
a button, you can
either accept or decline the
recommendation, and go ahead
and do it.
Again, there is an outage
here, so don't just
start clicking things.
But it's basically
propagated here,
so you can see what's happening.
So doing that is great.
But it's still
very manual, right?
So you have to log into the
cloud console, and one by one,
click the instances
and figure out
what action you want to take.
And so today, what I'm
excited to announce
is that we're going
to be enabling
programmatic access to these
rightsizing recommendations.
So we call it the
Rightsizing API.
And the idea here is you can
query the Rightsizing API,
get a list of recommendations,
all programmatically,
and then programmatically
decide if you want to take
the recommendation or not.
And then apply the rightsizing.
And so that would be a stop,
a resize, and then a restart.
And then you can take that
program that you've written
and schedule it so it
runs daily, or hourly,
or whatever it might be to keep
up with the churn of instances
that are coming on the fly.
So that you can stay ahead
of all of the new instances
that are getting
created so you don't
have to keep
logging in every day
and doing rightsizing manually.
So it's pretty cool.
It's in alpha today, and
it's coming to beta soon.
So keep an eye out for it if
you find this interesting.
So going back to
Example Inc, Example Inc
realized that they've been
running 96 core VMs when they
only really needed 72 core VMs.
And they're shrinking the memory
in the same proportion as well.
And as a result of that
change and rightsizing,
they're able to save about
5% on their total bill.
But they're not done
there yet, right?
So they have a whole
bunch of other resources.
So now they're moving
on, and now they're
looking at some of the
attached resources that
attached to the base VM, so
that second bucket of resources
that we talked about.
And so some of these resources
can be very expensive.
So GPUs, local SSD,
these are examples
of potentially very
expensive resources, where
small amount of waste can accrue
to a very large amount of cost
on your bill.
And again, the powers of 2 are
striking here again, right?
Compute Engine provides a
great deal more flexibility
with GPUs than you'll
find with other providers.
And so an example
here is, let's say
you have a use case where
you need 64 core VM.
In the power of 2 world,
there's a fixed ratio.
If you want 64 cores, you
have to get eight V100 GPUs.
But let's say you only need two.
Well, you don't have that
option in the predefined world
or the powers of 2 world.
With Compute Engine,
you can go ahead
and create that 64 core VM and
attach it to core V100 GPU.
And there's significant
savings here, right?
So just looking at the GPU
alone, it's $20 per hour
versus $5 an hour.
And so, Example Inc
took a look at this.
And they realized that they
could shrink their right V100s
to four V100s.
And as a result, they
saved another around 5%.
So with these two steps,
they're now saving about 10%
on their total spend right now.
So they're also using
persistent disk.
And persistent disk is a
cheaper resource for sure.
And you can have a lot
of persistent disk,
and it doesn't add up to that
much, especially when you're
comparing it to local
SSD, or GPUs, or even
the base core and RAM.
But a lot of VMs
have a lot of disks,
and a lot of cloud workloads
have a lot of churn,
where instances are
coming and going rapidly.
And so one of the things that
we've seen from some customers
is you end up in a situation
where instances get deleted,
but persistent disks that
were attached to the instance
don't get deleted.
And so you end up
with a whole bunch
of orphaned persistent
disks floating around.
And you can imagine if you
don't pay attention to this
for a long period of time,
and you have a lot of churn--
instances are coming and going--
you could end up with
thousands, hundreds or thousands
of persistent disks.
Or you might just start
hitting your quota limits--
prevent you from going too high.
So one tactical
thing you can do here
is when you're creating
your disk, or your instance,
or attaching the
disk to an instance,
you can set a flag to
have it auto delete.
And so when the
instance is deleted,
the persistent disks that
you've marked this flag on
will also get deleted.
So it's a great way to prevent
this orphaning problem that
could be happening.
One caution on this is it's
a very powerful tool, right?
It's a very, very
dangerous thing,
like in the sense of
if you delete the VM
and you actually want
the persistent disk,
there's a bunch of
warnings that will pop up
in the console, and in the cloud
interface, and all of that.
But if you keep
going to the yes,
yes, yes, that disk is
going to get deleted.
And if you actually
do need the data,
that's a really bad situation.
So use this fly
cautiously, especially
if you have different
people creating
instances and different
people deleting instances.
Then you may have
the right hand,
left hand issue happening.
But this is one thing that
we've seen customers leverage
to kind of prevent excess
waste in terms of PD.
So another thing you can do is
take advantage of snapshots.
So snapshots are 85% cheaper
than a running PD SSD
for the same amount of storage.
And so with a snapshot,
what you can do
is take a snapshot of
your disk and then delete
the persistent disk.
And the use case
there is, is you
have some PDs just floating
around that you don't need.
But you want the data.
You're not attached
to any instance.
So why not just
take the snapshot?
Save the data.
And then when you
need the data, you
can rehydrate that
snapshot back into a disk,
and then attach it to
a running instance.
And then the final thing here
on sort of-- these are very
tactical things, but the final
thing here is PD supports two
types of disks--
PD SSD, which is SSD,
and then PD standard.
PD standard is significantly
cheaper than PD SSD.
And not all workloads need the
performance characteristics
of SSDs.
So take a look at
your workloads,
and identify where it
makes sense to use SSD
and where it doesn't make sense.
And convert over to PD
standard where possible.
So we're going back
to Example Inc again.
Example Inc took a look
at their 120 terabytes,
and they realized that
about 14 terabytes of the PD
SSD that they've provisioned--
which is basically because they
had a whole bunch of
scripts, and everyone just
launched their instances,
and they just got PD SSD.
They realized that they
could cut 14 terabytes
and convert that to
PD at a standard.
So that results in like a 1%
to 2% increase in savings now.
So smaller than the
larger instances,
but that's kind of
the point, right?
You're going to want to spend
your time on where you're
spending the most money first to
get the best bang for your buck
and then go down
that list of sort
of the most expensive resource
all the way down to the least
expensive resource.
So now they're at 11%,
which is not bad, right?
And we've been at this
for maybe 20 minutes now.
We've saved them 11%
off of 1.5 million.
Not bad.
Another thing you can do is
leverage preemptible resources.
And so preemptible
resources is basically
our most discounted offering.
It provides up to 80% off
of normal on demand prices.
But it comes with some slightly
different characteristics.
The resources act and look
just like a normal resource,
so the performance
will be the same.
Availability is the same.
However, you can only keep
the resource for 24 hours.
And there's a slight
chance that you may be
preempted before the 24 hours.
So you may be asking, whoa,
who would use this, right?
If you have applications that
can checkpoint and tolerate
sort of VMs coming and
going and restarting
at a certain checkpoint,
this is a great way
to save a lot of money on
some of your workloads.
So some examples here are sort
of batch workloads, rendering.
Things like that use
preemptible resources heavily.
All right, so we're going
to switch to something
a little more nichey
now, and we're
going to talk about licensing.
There's two types of licenses
I want to talk about today.
The first is vCPU
based licenses.
So you may have some
software that you've
purchased that the software
provider says you can run it
in the cloud, but you have to
license it based on each vCPU
that you're running.
You also may have some workloads
that are heavily memory bound
and not compute bound.
So databases are a
great example of this,
where you need a whole
boatload of memory
and not a lot of compute power.
And so we have a feature
called extended memory
that's directly addressed
at this type of use case.
And the idea here is, is
that extended memory allows
you to create VMs with much
higher memory to vCPU ratios
than you can get
with custom machine
types or predefined
machine types.
So for example, you could
have a VM with one vCPU
and 500 gigabytes of RAM.
And so if you were to take that
use case with a vCPU license,
you would be responsible to
pay for one vCPU license.
But your workload
and your database
would still have 500 gigabytes
of memory to work with.
One thing I would
call out here is
there is an extra cost
for using extended memory.
So you're going to
want to do the math
and say, what is the
cost per vCPU that I add?
What is the cost?
And then what is the cost
for enabling extended memory?
And so, do that math.
And many customers that I've
talked to for certain software
licenses, extended memory
makes just a whole lot of sense
because the vCPU licenses
dwarf the cost of the actual VM
itself.
Another type of license
that I want to talk--
the second type of license
I want to talk about
is server bound licenses.
So these are
licenses that require
you to license the physical
cores or physical sockets
of a server.
This is not something that
you could do on Compute Engine
before.
You may have noticed
in the keynote today,
we announced support for bring
your own license on sole tenant
nodes.
And so the idea
here is we're now
going to expose the
physical characteristics
of our sole tenant nodes.
So you'll know that there's
x sockets, y physical cores,
which means now if you have some
of these server bound licenses,
you can bring them onto
the sole tenant nodes.
So Windows is a great example
of this, Windows Server.
Windows server is a
great example of this.
So before this
feature, if you wanted
to run Windows on
Compute Engine,
you would have to buy a
license from Compute Engine.
And even though you may already
have Windows Server licenses
that you purchased through
Microsoft or through one
of their third party
authorized dealers--
which is kind of
wasteful, right?
You're basically paying
for two licenses.
You can only use one of them.
It doesn't seem super fair.
So what you can do now is you
can take the licenses that you
have on-prem or
that you've bought,
and you can bring them
over to Compute Engine
via this feature,
sole tenant BYOL.
And so the example here is
these Microsoft licenses
can be quite expensive.
So just on the
server license alone,
it's more than the
instance cost itself.
So you could save more
than 55% on Compute Engine
today if you just bring your
own licenses for Windows Server.
But you could imagine
that this starts
to get really,
really cheaper if you
think that you're running, say,
Microsoft SQL Server on it as
well.
So if you remember, we talked
about Example Inc. Example
Inc did have a small
footprint of Windows licenses.
They had 192 Windows
core licenses
that they were purchasing
through Compute Engine.
With this new BYOL
feature, they basically
spun up some sole tenant nodes.
They launched their Windows
VMs into the sole tenant nodes.
And as a result, they stopped
paying Google and Compute
Engine for these
Windows licenses
and instead, are able to
reuse the licenses that they
have today.
And the savings here add up
to another, I think, 3% to 4%.
And so now we're up to about
15% total savings here.
So we've gone through a whole
bunch of different things,
in terms of being able to
reduce your bill from a resource
perspective.
And so the whole
point of this is
to take all of the waste that's
happening with the resources
that you're running and bring
it down to just exactly what
you need, right?
And there'll be
some noise there,
but that's the whole point
of that section three,
is to figure out how do you
shrink this down so that what
you're using and
what you're being
charged for is the minimum
amount that you actually need.
Once you do that, then
it's time to start
thinking about, OK, now I've got
this minimum amount of usage.
How do I optimize the
discounts available to me?
So the first one, we've
talked a little bit about it,
but it's super simple and easy.
It's sustained use discounts,
and the basic premise here
is the more you run,
the more you save.
Up to 30% off if you run the
resource for the entire month.
And this is something
that we've continued.
This is something that we
launched many years ago,
and we've continued to
invest in it to try and make
it more flexible and more fair.
And so today, what
you can do now
is you can start
and stop VMs freely.
You can change the
shape of your VMs,
so you can go from n1
standard 4 to n1 standard 16.
The sustained use
discount will continue
to accrue on a core and RAM
basis, independent of those two
things.
And you can change
zones within a region.
So this gives you a whole
boatload of flexibility
with sustained use discount.
So you can run these
different instances.
Things can change over time.
And at the end of the month,
we'll look at what you ran
and if you ran a resource
across different zones
in the same region and
different VM types.
But if that core ran for
a full 30 days or 31 days,
you'll get 30% off.
And so we're going to do
that calculation for you,
and it's only fair, right?
We're going to give you
the optimal discount based
on the usage that
you're getting.
So a little bit of
complexity that I
want to add here that
has been recently added,
is we do split sustained use
discount into two buckets
today.
So we have something
called the general purpose
bucket and the memory
optimized bucket.
So general purpose VMs are the
n1 standard, the n1 highmem,
and the n1 highcpu, as well
as custom machine types
and sole tenant nodes.
And memory optimized are
memory optimized VMs.
So these are n1 megamem
and n1 ultramem.
And so what I mean by
separate buckets is
that when I was saying
that you could change
VM shapes, if you were to change
between a general purpose VM
and a memory optimized VM,
the sustained use discounts
don't stack.
These are two different
pools or usage graphs
that we look at to
optimize in terms of cost.
So I think an example might
make this a little clearer.
So here's an example.
You're running an n1
standard 4 for half a month.
And then there's some event.
You get a whole bunch
of new traffic pop in.
And as a result, you increase
the size of your VM 2 and n1
standard 16.
So it's only fair you ran four
cores for the entire month,
right?
So sustained use counts
will give you 30% discount
on those four cores.
And for the remaining
12 cores that are there,
that got added as part
of the n1 standard
16, that ran for half a month.
So you'll get
around 10% discount,
which is the half the
month type discount.
So going along, so now if we
have to separate sustained use
buckets, let's say you
started with an n1 standard 4
and then you converted
to a n1 megamem--
whatever.
So different
sustained use buckets.
In that scenario, you'd
only get half a month
sustained use discount for the
n1 standard and then a half
a month discount
for the megamem.
So you'd only get
the 10% discount.
Those four cores
won't get the 30%.
So something to be aware of.
So there's some
restrictions in terms
of the different instances
that you change, too.
There are some restrictions
that are happening there.
So sustained use
discounts is pretty cool
because you don't have to
send any signal to Google
and say, hey, I'm
going to run this.
And you still get
up to a 30% discount
if you happen to run
for the entire month.
But in some use cases,
you may actually
know that you have
some steady state
workloads that are going to run
for one or three years or even
longer.
And in those
scenarios, you should
be able to get an even lower
price or a bigger discount.
And so for that, we have
something called committed use
discounts.
And the idea with
committed use discounts
is in exchange for a one
or three year commitment,
you get a deeply
discounted price.
And so for one year, you'll get
37% off, and for three year,
you get 55% off.
And we've tried to make
committed use discounts very
similar to sustained
use discounts in terms
of flexibility and fairness.
So with a committed
use discount,
you tell us in
aggregate what you want.
So you could say, I want
10,000 cores and 5,000
or 50,000 gigabytes of RAM.
You don't have to tell
us the machine shapes,
or specific zones,
or operating systems.
And so as you start
spinning up those VMs,
if things have to change-- those
VMs shut down and come back,
or you change instance types
within the general purpose
pool or the memory
optimized pool,
the discounts will just accrue.
And another use case
that we've seen is--
and I think it's
pretty neat-- is
that when you get to
really large scale,
although any single
user or project may have
a lot of volatility,
when you start
to add a huge amount of projects
and a huge amount of usage,
these customers will start
to notice that there are sort
of these low watermarks that
they can buy committed use
discounts out.
So they're not actually
buying for a specific workload
that they know is steady.
They just know that in
aggregate across all the noise
within the organization,
they're always going
to have 50,000 cores running.
And they may burst 100,000
cores at any point,
but they know that they're
never going to go below that.
So it's an ideal
thing to purchase.
So committed use
discounts is maybe
one of the most
popular pricing models
we've seen on Compute Engine
for the last couple of years.
And so today, I'm really
excited-- something
I have been working on.
I'm really excited to
announce that we're
expanding committed
use discounts
to additional resources.
So we're going to support
GPUs, as well as local SSD.
And so, it works very similar
to committed use discounts
for cores and RAM.
So you can do a one
year or a three year.
And you'll get the similar
discounts, 37% for one year,
55% for a three year.
And we're going to support
all of the GPU types
that we have today.
So the K80, the P4,
the P100, and the V100.
And the T4 is something that
we announced, I think, today.
So that's coming
very soon, and we'll
be supporting that as well.
So if you are running
GPU workloads that
have some sort of
steady state workload,
this is a great way
to save some money.
So if you know you're
going to run it
for three years
or even one year,
it makes sense to buy these.
I'm also excited--
this is something
I've also been working on.
I'm also excited to introduce
a brand new billable resource
that you have to worry about.
They're called
zonal reservations.
And the idea here is they
provide peace of mind
that resources will
be available for you
when and where you want them.
And so the idea
here is you can say,
I need to make sure that I
always have 101 standard 32's
in US central 1a.
So that's a specific zone
and a specific machine shape.
You can create
these reservations.
And so long as we
grant the reservation,
you now know that those
resources are there for you.
And you can convert
them into running
instances whenever you want.
And there's a bunch of
different use cases here.
Some of the use cases
are for example,
let's say you want
to do a patch.
And so you're patching, and
you're doing a rolling patch.
And some instances get deleted.
You want to make sure that
you have enough resources
to make sure that you can
complete the operation
and come back in
a healthy state.
So that's one of the things
that's going on there.
So one of the
things that we tried
to do really hard
with reservations
was, again, live by
those three principles
that we talked about--
simplicity, flexibility,
and fairness.
And so these reservations
are effectively just
like running instances, from
Compute Engine's perspective.
And so any of the discounts
you may have purchased already,
like a committed use discount
or even sustained use discounts,
should just apply like
it's a running instance.
So if you purchased some
committed use discounts,
you can imagine that
these reservations look
and act just like an instance
from a discounting perspective.
So if you happen to say, I
bought a CUD for this running
instance, and I now want
to make it a reservation,
you can do that, and the
committed use discounts
will still work.
And so similarly, on the
sustained use perspective,
sustained use
discount perspective,
we'll have reservations
for general purpose VMs,
as well as memory optimized VMs.
And so when you create
those reservations,
they'll feed into those two
different sustained use buckets
that we talked about.
Another new feature
that we're adding--
sorry, I should
actually go back.
So these are coming
to beta very soon.
In the next couple
of weeks, you'll
see this become available.
And another feature that
is currently in alpha today
is what we call committed use
discount analysis reports.
And so these are first class
reports within the billing
UI within cloud console.
And they're meant to
help you understand.
If you've purchased
some CUDs, it'll
help you understand what
the financial impact
of those things are.
So you can get a sense
of am I utilizing my CUD?
Am I under utilizing my CUD?
Should I be buying more CUDs?
That type of thing.
So that takes me to the
end of this session.
There's a few breakout
sessions I want to call out.
The main one that I think
is super interesting that I
think will resonate with
folks in the room is CST301.
And so, one of my colleagues
will be talking about many
of the sort of
cost saving things
that we've talked
about that we're
doing sort of in a
manual way and doing it
in sort of an automated way.
And so there's a whole bunch
of cool demos and code snippets
that are going to
be available there.
So I strongly encourage you,
if you found this interesting,
to check that out.
It should be super cool.
And then I'd like to just
thank everyone for attending.
And thank the production
team in the back as well.
You guys are awesome.
Thank you so much.
And then one sort
of bookkeeping item,
there is a survey for
all of the sessions.
So if you take some
time, please fill it out.
Positive or negative feedback
is more than welcome.
I'd love to hear what
everyone thought.
So now, let's open
it up to questions.
Yeah, does anyone
want to come down?
Or we can start with the Dory.
Oh, I think we have someone--
maybe not.
I'm calling out, sorry.
All right, let's start
with the Dory then.
SPEAKER: Cool.
There was one
question on the Dory
that was answered
later in the slides,
but it's worth calling
out just to re-emphasize.
The question is, for
instance, rightsizing,
what other ways can
this be captured
outside of the console?
Can this be an event on Pub/Sub
or exposed via another API?
And I think you answered
that a little bit later
in the talk, where it
is the Rightsizing API
is available now
as an alpha API,
and we'll be launching
the beta soon.
So you'll be able to consume
those programmatically
via that API.
MANISH DALWADI: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
It's going to be super
cool, and if you're
interested in the
alpha, just reach out.
It's my last name at Google.com.
So just reach out, and we
can try and get you guys
into the alpha.
SPEAKER: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Most Compute Engines
are SAP based.
And their cost is huge.
MANISH DALWADI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Every time we're
asking or we're looking at it,
we're getting the answer
that SAP only certified this.
I saw the flexibility
of nodes versus cores,
memory versus cores,
because most of our systems
are not production.
Only the production has to be
standardized and SAP certified.
All the other ones, we can
really manipulate it the way
we want.
Is that something
we should look into,
or is this something that
SAP is show stopping it?
Or what's--
MANISH DALWADI: Scott, you
may know this better than me.
But I think it really depends
on the use case, right?
So if you are doing sort
of a test environment,
you probably want
the environment
to be very similar to
what you're actually going
to be deploying to production.
If you're doing
some toy stuff, it
seems reasonable that you
can at least play with it.
But again, I think
you have to make
sure the SAP's OK with allowing
you to do some of this stuff.
AUDIENCE: But for example,
obviously, the quality system
has to be as production.
But for a project
testing, the data
is the same size as production.
However, the Compute Engine
or the CPUs, the disk,
and all that extra cost that we
see that maybe we can minimize.
MANISH DALWADI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this
something that--
everything that basically
question, everything you
said to the Compute
Engine, does that
apply to the SAP Compute
Engines or the SAP templates
that we use?
SPEAKER: I think for the
non-production use workloads,
yeah, I believe that's--
non-production use cases
for the SAP software
and deployment, all
that stuff applies.
I think the key with
the SAP certification
and then the trigger
of the licensing
is like the production workloads
require a specific machine
shape, a specific
configuration of PD SSD,
et cetera, and a specific guest
OS, like [INAUDIBLE] for SAP,
et cetera.
That's what triggers kind of the
production aspect of your SAP
deployment.
And that's where, I think,
the specific machine shapes
and all those config needs
to be met before they support
that as a production workload.
And in supporting that
as a production workload,
then they also charge the
production licensing costs.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
MANISH DALWADI: Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so what's
your vision for provisioning
the instance type via API?
You showed that the provision
[INAUDIBLE] but our customers
would be more interested
to see those things,
like instance types, via
APIs and on the rightscale
because it's easier to see it,
rather than using BigQuery.
Because all the
other cloud providers
provide that API, so that you
can see those instance type
and you see the cloud
spend or the instance--
MANISH DALWADI: Oh, I see.
So API access to the
BigQuery export data.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I think right now, we
do not see those things
provisioned via Rightscale, as
you see it for AWS or Azure.
So that's missing.
So how do you
provision to have--
MANISH DALWADI: Sorry.
I'll step away from that.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: How do you envision
it to provide those access to--
MANISH DALWADI: Yeah, I
mean, I think the data
we want to share, right?
So fundamentally, this is just
a sort of prioritization thing,
right?
So I think as we get more
feedback of this type of thing,
these are things
that we can add.
And so I can't
specifically speak
to what we're doing, but--
AUDIENCE: But that's a real
frustration for our customers
that it's not able to
access via the third-party--
or Google doesn't
allow the API system.
MANISH DALWADI: So, just
so it's super clear to me,
the ask is the
ability to query--
AUDIENCE: The instance type.
MANISH DALWADI: The
instance type from the API.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MANISH DALWADI: Got it, OK.
Actually, so it's not
about the BigQuery export.
It's about being able to look
at what's running right now
and call the API's.
AUDIENCE: There's
an option that you
showed at the beginning
of the presentation
that you can use SKUs and then--
MANISH DALWADI: Instance dot
list and instance describe.
AUDIENCE: It's
inconvenient rather
than having a visualization
via doing it by BigQuery.
MANISH DALWADI: Got it, OK.
That's good feedback.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: So there's another
question from the Dory.
Are you going to allow
moving committed use
discounts between projects?
MANISH DALWADI: So I can't
announce anything specifically,
but this is something
that we hear constantly.
And our roadmap is
driven by customer asks.
So just keep your ears out.
SPEAKER: Any plans to
include PD SSDs in CUD?
Like offer CUDs for PD SSDs.
MANISH DALWADI: Yeah,
so this is something
that I've been discussing
with our internal team
in terms of how we want
to expand community use
discounts beyond just sort
of Compute Engine in general.
And so this is something
that we are looking at.
There's nothing
immediate that's coming.
But totally get it.
I think some of the
challenges on the PD side
is that PD tends to be
fairly cheap already,
so I'm not sure if we're going
to be able to offer, say,
a 55% off discount for a three
year commitment on some PD.
So there's some viability things
that we need to look at there.
SPEAKER: And the last one
from the Dory if there's
no more in the room--
it's not quite a question,
but maybe it's
something that you
can provide some insight into.
You need to have an essay
agreement with Microsoft
to gain mobility.
Also, there are restrictions
on Microsoft applications
that actually have
mobility rights.
OS is not one of them.
And then they provide a
link for more information.
I'm not sure what
that translates to.
MANISH DALWADI: Yeah.
Yeah.
So it's super confusing.
I get it.
And so as part of the BYOL
launch, the beta launch that
went out today,
actually, there's
going to be documentation that
talks about what's allowed,
what's not allowed,
and gives guidance.
In the end, you do need to
look at your EA with Microsoft
and make sure that
it is in compliance.
But a lot of these EAs tend
to be standard language.
And so there will
be material that's
part of the sole tenant
BYOL documentation that
talks about this in detail.
[MUSIC PLAYING]